but i'm sure many are wondering caisson
why are you here in your v tuber form
and not your your human form
that's true that's true
why not because people love me in this
form more
all right all right yeah
um but i kind of feel comfortable in
this form
because i don't have to put my makeup on
you know that that is something that i
find very envious with every youtuber
that you just you just turn on the
camera you don't need to like give a
[ __ ] about how you look yeah yeah i
usually don't give a [ __ ]
i i do morning streams i wake up i like
i got hit by a truck and i'm i'm live
and everyone's like connor you look dead
every stream without fail someone's like
connie looked tired like no [ __ ] that's
what happens when you wake up
it's like it could be 3 p.m and i still
look like [ __ ] yeah i just don't care
anymore like i just permanently have eye
bags so you can tell whenever i'm
recording something late at night or
early in the morning because i always
always without fail get the comments of
oh have you been sleeping enough
i was like oh thanks mum no i've been
sleeping enough don't worry about it oh
my general practitioner here uh it seems
like ghansky not getting enough sleep oh
my god
oh my god wait do you prefer so do you
prefer actually doing youtuber streams
or
how can i say 3d streaming
because you've done a lot of
irl live action whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it before right
i call it a 3d high polygon
all right all right all right unreal
engine
for me 4. me that's a super high polygon
model right right
rtx
before we get into it do you want to
explain to the viewers what you do and
what you do for streaming and everything
like that yes oh yeah um um i'm uh i'm a
delinquent v tuber um i debuted on
october 16th so i'm kind of
uh
a new a new one of
face um but i've been streaming for um
i've been doing this for like um three
years and
five years ago i started um
filming videos of me playing games and
and then after
that
oh
um i
thought i would like
let's do the youtuber stuff because i'm
i'm tired of putting makeup on
the high polio myself
because you've done a lot of cosplay
stuff right you did a lot of cosplay
streams right cosplay stuff but that's
like the antithesis of putting on makeup
yeah like you put a lot of makeup on
yeah yeah makeup's like step one right
yeah
and then it's like 20 steps after that
yeah how much prep do you have to do for
a cosplay stream whenever you're
cosplaying someone first of all um i
make all my cosplay costumes oh wow
from scratch really yeah um i'm good at
showing
so i'm i make it myself so
step zero i have to
buy those stuff
wow make it so you don't just buy a wish
like this guy whatever
you don't buy from amazon uh yeah man
trying to find an adult minecraft steve
costume it's very difficult
i have i have a shirt and a pair of
pants that is the exact same coloration
i want like the blocks right i've been
trying to find a minecraft steve costume
and it's been very difficult because
everyone i've i've purchased or seen is
for the ages of six to twelve
now i'm thinking one so i ended up just
buying the six to twelve one and frankly
i'll just i'll make it work squeezing
i'll just i'll just rip that thing like
this make it for you yeah you should
keep your case on
can i can i do that maybe i'll maybe
i'll do that i don't know what your
rates are it's probably very expensive
actually i didn't know you made your own
cosplays how long does it take to make
um
if i concentrate maybe for like three
days if you use a hundred percent that's
a bigger percent of my brain power and
concentrate well usually i can't do that
so it takes about like two
weeks that yeah that sounds real because
like i've seen some of your cosplay
streams in the past yeah and like i
remember the you did one for bayonetta
yeah the banana yeah the banana
i see clips everywhere yeah yeah and i'm
like and i'm like how the hell did you
make that by yourself because that's
better than like some like professional
bandit cosplays that i've seen oh thank
you was that like the longest one you
did what's the longest one you that took
you maybe bayonetta because her hair
yeah
costume her hair i had to um buy like um
three wigs right three
wigs and like um mess it up and like oh
did you see did you see that over there
on the screen yeah yeah yeah yeah
that like hairband thing that like
defies physics it's actually like built
actually spongebob's home that's been
relocated
it's so hard i had to throw away like
three wigs and i messed up a lot of wigs
so much money and time
i can see why you do this now
yeah now
you've had like uh you know a very uh
long and famous career doing this this
stuff and it's really impressive one
thing that i um
kind of
weirdly impressed by because this is one
thing that i find that people really
struggle to do
is that you have mainly uh is it correct
instead of a japanese audience mainly
ah yeah but you also have an english
following yeah and it's normally really
hard for creators to balance
two different languages yeah yeah in
fact because like a lot of the platforms
just don't want you to speak both
languages yeah because they want to know
okay you speak english we're
recommending you to english speakers you
speak japanese only japanese speakers
are getting it no how do you find
balancing that like because you know
it's way beyond my my ability
i'm figuring it out to be honest um
like for
the japanese viewers they
um
they don't like me speaking mostly in
english because
obviously
yeah yeah
and um well but i mostly my viewers are
mostly japanese and i mostly do
um the streams on in japanese
so
sorry what gave you the idea to try and
branch out to a more international
audience that's that's what i'm curious
about or was it just your you had a
language you know skill set and you just
wanted to flex it kind of
um
i don't know yeah maybe
maybe yeah let's
i guess it's like if you or is it dumb
luck
i'm just gonna give it a go see if it
works kind of thing you just wing it
like that
i'm like um yeah let's try it if it
works out good like i'm that kind of
person and there you go
think and like she's trying to die i
just do it she's just a genius what can
i say
yeah i'm just a genius delinquent yeah
i'm envious of you being able to speak
great japanese and english i'm
jerry's also
yeah yeah but the thing is i haven't
been able to diversify my audience as
much as caisson as i feel have you tried
to like capture a japanese audience at
all and are you even interested in
i just i'm personally just not really
interested in it just because it's like
i don't know it's just because i feel
it's just so
different in terms of like content and
stuff like that like if it's kind of
like you know like what kson does where
it's like whole variety stuff right like
where you can just basically do whatever
the hell you want yeah then it's a
little bit easier to try and branch out
right but i don't know it's also a lot
of effort to do both yeah what i mean i
don't know if this is correct right i
could be completely wrong i've heard
some stories about people who have
audiences both like some youtubers uh
they subtitled their stuff in japanese
yeah and they have quite a decent
japanese following uh
the main the main thing i've been told
is that japanese people have no chill
online uh that's the one thing yeah one
criticism that i've heard a lot it's
it's scary at least that's from from an
english perspective yeah i don't know is
what is it like having the two different
types of audiences do you notice a
difference between them both like
distinctly other than the language other
than the language um
well
i don't know japanese people
like well it's just from my perspective
okay
of course it's illegal it's all opinions
i just said they had no chill i think
i'm in trouble probably
um japanese people mostly um don't want
to see my
3d high polygon stuff right right it's
just it's not like they don't love me as
in that style it's like um they could
i don't know relate more to the anime
yeah wow
i don't know i
that's the part i don't understand much
yeah yeah because you're the same person
right yeah
it's just one's 2d and one's a 3d
polygon playing a character or anything
like at all are you
well i i am a delinquent um
she is a delinquent she is a delinquent
i'm not playing a character i'm just
delinquent yeah yeah i was born
delinquent um
um and what was i talking about
i guess so it kind of makes sense right
because you know otherwise if if the
japanese audience didn't have this like
infatuation with these 2d streamers then
v-tubing wouldn't really be a thing in
the first place i feel
that's
it's weird like that infatuation had to
come from somewhere right yeah and like
japan is already like especially japan's
like otaku culture is already so
obsessed with like
you know the whole 2d thing i mean i got
the western brain i don't know that's
not like a disease i've got westerners
i'm trying to like i'm trying to wrap my
head around it is to give possible
reasons such a strange concept because
like my parents
like have no like don't understand the
whole v tubing thing at all but they're
like but they're always so curious being
like why is it that people like this and
it's so hard to explain to them why it's
like they'll never understand right